this is mr. Gregg we're back and I got
my coffee yes adorable in adorable size
get a little petunias or some dances
flowers and but much like hit this
episode was adorable
fuck adorable this episode was wonderful
uh this this might be my favorite one at
least like adorable now you're gonna
give me caught on the in and I was gonna
say adorable um uh uh Wow don't want to
know your circus oh hi Japanese sites
probably oh all right we've ruined
another v-log I got my coffee I'm ready
to go and it was such a good episode I
guess I mean either if not my favorite
that way like my top three you know I
the first minute I really thought oh
shit this is gonna blow I hope I got
that I think the burger commercial after
we did the bur okay I shouldn't say that
the burger commercial was fine when it
got into the song about what do we do
with our ten million dollars Empire City
what about like I was just like oh my
god our worst night what we were talking
I was like us is gonna become about the
money now we got this stupid song
sequence they're gonna go on some
fucking vacation and do whatever they
want I really thought our not easy not
fair Oh kiss or something but this and
why would it turn around after they got
to the hotel starting with that mr. with
that uh Citizen Kane song yeah oh no I
always ever since and I always think of
Simpson sir that's mr. Billings um and
yeah I mean this is the closest to like
just a like a good Broadway musical in a
Steven universe episode all the songs
are phenomenal all of them do what
they're supposed to do it's the emotions
through it are just fantastic that you
feel the emotion of every song and I'm
glad every song it feels like you know
there's one that they cut off uh but but
you know for comedic purposes an
emotional purposes I feel like we got
one song yeah I feel
but God like the emotion that every song
was supposed to try and get into you and
man that uh if that's the same voice
actress it does pearl what a voice
I mean just everything this episode
visually it was wonderful the story was
wonderful the characters in the way they
interacted off each well and was just so
wonderful and as I have stated on many
occasions I am a pearl girl
um at you where is peridot and lapis for
that matter the more I think they kind
of disappeared they got written off the
show braids they asked for way too much
money so you know peridot I mean she
wanted to be the star there was
something that happened like before the
floating episode they're like oh we've
been away for so long and we don't know
what happened cuz before there was the
baseball episode at least the list I was
looking through it says that's the
episode um well maybe they were there
was just the game I don't know yeah
watching these out-of-order net no no
they show can I guess I have been
looking on the list it says this is the
order so but I'm mistaken but what a
great Perl episode aggressive girl girl
I approve what you know and honestly
like I get you know the father is fine
but I never got just kind of not my
character kind of thing really except
for him both of them yeah um and yeah I
don't know that just I can't believe
that fucking worked like a bully really
well you know what I'm not for sure this
was not gonna work and I'm like wow this
may be one of the best episodes they've
done well and the foot of turn around in
five minutes I know this is like the
message of it everything but the same
time really the reason the episode
worried really was not about the money
it wasn't it was that short little bit
the model it turns out was an excuse
just to get them to this position to do
these things yeah where it's like the
focus was not you don't need money like
that's not really the message it's more
than money wasn't MacGuffin yeah it
really was just rude
that's when you have your coffee if you
get it right I was Germans by the way he
looked
I'm not insane I looked it up something
like eighty percent of Germans DJing or
something
somebody I did I I just looked up at
some he's like must be a very
interesting town just world they live in
but cuz I swore I heard that I'm like
I'm not so in the morning and I'm under
the weather and tired and haven't had my
coffee but I swear this thing's like I
swear to God I heard Germans well as
soon as they show that city uh you know
that first backdrop of that city I mean
they just gorgeously show show this
place and I love anything I mean any
kind of environment you can make look
beautiful you know kudos but I like it
when they can take because I think
people like to show you know cities
looking bad and corruption and all that
stuff and how dirty it can be but I like
when they can show us it really looking
beautiful it looks it it looks like
Epcot centers like New York kind of or
something like World Showcase you're in
oh but it was Las Vegas kind of New York
and like herds is like this collection
of buildings but yeah I all the songs
were really good yeah I I didn't I am
like the one about going to Empire City
that much that one just kinda like the
first half and I like that yeah it was
oh it was okay I thought that was
passable I'm like I was alright but
again I kind of a like this from when
they arrived at Empire City on all the
songs are really strong well and I think
the I like the way they come back to and
they reuse them I mean they really do
what like a very good Broadway musical
does they serve use these songs and
themes almost like you know they'll
bring them back and then reuse them and
they'll you know have them means
something totally different at different
scene and have a different character
sing about it I that Hotel song that's
where it had me yeah I'm like okay this
Emily
well again I'm thinking like okay it's
gonna be the you know out-of-towner who
doesn't fit in with the new money and
stuff but I mean those those serpents
were very funny I love only gives them
light to the piano plays like
like what the fuck was it but I was
laughing it's a lot of things are it's
like they so want to deal have you a
Mustang yeah
like they want to do the stereotype of
the stuck-up you know waiter serving
whatever I mean so it's just like you
know boy what have to see I'm wondering
I was getting the impression maybe I'm
wrong well we'll see where they go in
future episodes but I was getting the
president the joke was they may have
dismantled and a million which I would
be fine with I mean yeah I'd actually be
totally fine because I'm not sure I like
the idea that they're rich I kind of
like that their dad was kind of a biz
dad was a blue-collar type working at a
car wash and then 10-million I mean it's
like that even for a place like that I
mean that's too hot to go through but it
would be funny um but I love when
they're finally coming together and
dancing I love that they had them in
different colors the the yellow against
the blue I love that um I love that they
sort of do it through both song and
talking at the same time um you know
with Stephen playing and sing the song
that them actually sir is speaking um
and it's one of the few times where you
know when he says it's always been like
this and this isn't going to be wrapped
up like this I was thinking I like that
you know shows like this don't
necessarily think we have to wrap this
up in whatever half-hour ten minutes and
even though this technically kind of
does at the end it still was kind of
burned because we've had episode after
episode emphasizing this problem I think
they realized more so pearl than because
pearls the one I think with more of the
hang-up um the dad seems like he could
be fine with pearl it's just pearl
doesn't want that but I think the two of
them realized that in the same way Rose
drove them apart they suddenly realize
that Rose also brings them together that
one line about just like well she always
did what she wanted like I felt like
they came to an understanding there yeah
um well and we saw a little bit with
them at this too like they Sarah had a
connection and of a comfortable to and
again there to love that pearl white I
found out recently that three is a crap
I am one even the whole thing I feel
like it was just a perfect balance of
something that was legitimately funny
but legitimately
he you know hartfeld is as well in the
opening when she's about burgers really
this was the say yes I love it really
that's what did it for Rose burgers she
see this Roger Rabbit seriously what do
you see this guy but but I love when she
also says you know she would have loved
it and walks away that was both really
funny and really really heartbreaking at
the same time and I felt this whole
episode had that really good balance of
that um so yeah yeah trying to think I
can't think it's too much else it's just
so well done such a good good episode
and just visually beautiful too like I
said I mean the backgrounds in the city
and the music I mean it's just is this
is like a perfect episode to me I just
can't really think of anything that
wrong with it it's just everything you
want to do it just did flawless clothes
rocky start but very very close to
absolute perfect even with the Empire
City song though I mean it's very much
it's the show tune it's the I serve like
taking this very simple nice humble song
and going to this big show number but
then by the end it comes back to the
very humble simple song um so I almost
want to say it was kind of meant to be
over the top kind of like you know
almost the Heartless I you know just hey
let's go pizzazz and show and stuff like
that so I almost finished just a my kind
of thing I mean it's it's not my thing
either but I I still respect it for like
wanted to cheap it was supposed to be
kind of I mean that being said I love
this episode and I love coffee
um but yeah well done man I can't think
of anything else man why is it man why
is it the man the man that Rebecca sugar
nut back a bestial rocks
and bear up shed Robert you know this
episode so good we should go out hide a
bite